ALICIA GOODE: I first started
experimenting with taxidermy
when I was a little kid.
I remember making shoe box
dioramas for my friends.
Some of my friends parents
weren't too thrilled
about that, but I
thought it was great.
My name's Alicia Goode, and
I'm an exhibits preparator
at the Oakland
Museum of California.
One of the things that I
really love about taxidermy
as a profession is that
it's a great melding
of a lot of the areas
that I'm passionate about.
So I've always been
artistically inclined
and I've always loved nature.
I started out pursuing
a degree in zoology,
but then I decided to
switch to fine art.
And I actually didn't
end up finishing school
because I got a job
at a big museum.
And so I quit school to
avoid going into debt
and just turned full-time
and never looked back.
I think the work that
we did at the Oakland
Museum of California was
one of the biggest projects
that I've been involved with.
And there was a grizzly
bear in particular that
was just in horrible shape.
We also got a herd of Tule Elk.
They were also pretty damaged
or even older than the bear was.
They were collected in 1910.
And I think that to
pull off a nice mount
and to have it be believable
is to amass as much reference
you can and get to
know the species.
See them up close in life
and learn their attitudes
and posturing.
People sometimes
think it's creepy.
I don't think it's
creepy at all.
There's no fascination with
death or morbid aesthetic
that I'm really going after.
The most rewarding
part of my job
is knowing that I'm
creating something
that might inspire people
to care about nature
and want to conserve it.
Hopefully through going
to natural history museums
and seeing taxidermy
and dioramas,
they'll learn about all
these different kinds
of animals and environments.
And hopefully through
knowing about them
and caring about them
and being interested
and then, they'll want to
protect them in the future.
SUBJECT 1: Are you pursuing
a unique career path?
Let us know in the
comments below.
And to find out how a former
corporate lawyer gave up
his career to be a
full-time LEGO artist,
check out this video right here.
SUBJECT 2: I left
the law firm behind
to play with bricks full-time.
The bricks I use in my art
are the very same bricks
that people could
purchase at a toy store.
I don't paint them.
I don't have access to special
colors or special shapes
and sizes.
And we're in my art
studio today where I have
over five million LEGO bricks.
SUBJECT 1: Thanks for watching
and be sure to subscribe
for more Seeker stories.